War is coming
when the stakes are this high
It takes a master and an apprentice
to defeat our enemy.
What makes someone ready?
You just know.
Oh, oh,
oh, oh, oh.
Keep your lid on chop.
You felt it?
We all have.
There's just a generational impact
that Star Wars has had on my
and so many families
across the world.
When I think of how much I loved it
as a kid,
to actually have the Montrose on the lake
and the costume,
it just feels magical.
When I watched The Mandalorian with my mom
and I say, May the force be with you.
She literally did like a slow turn
towards me with tears in her eyes.
I feel grateful to be a part
of something so truly iconic.
Getting to play a soldier has
been an absolute dream come true.
It's very personal
and it's my honor to be a soldier.
Her bravery, her passion, her power.
Soldier is truly one of a kind.
Welcome back everyone
it's Charlie
This will be my new Ahsoka trailer video.
There's a whole bunch of new footage.
Easter eggs in.
The big surprise is the Star Wars.
People are going to air
the episodes a day early now.
Now, episodes every week are going to air
on Tuesday nights at 6 p.m.
Pacific Time. I'll be doing episode videos
for all them.
So if you're brand new to the channel,
be sure to subscribe to get those
and I'll try to post those
as soon as I can on Tuesday nights,
at least by Wednesday mornings.
Early.
they're dropping
the first two episodes back to back.
So like my episode one video
will probably post on Tuesday night later
and then my episode two video will post
Wednesday morning earlier
and that's Pacific Time
What is this special kind of giveaway
during the episode videos too?
there's a couple cool Star Wars things
I have left to give away
based on all the early reviews.
It sounds like the series is going
to be pretty solid, which is awesome.
But you're starting the beginning
of the trailer footage working
way through, shot by shot, talking about
Easter eggs, wtf moments, the Anakin
Skywalker of it all at the Luke
Skywalker Grogu who Mandalorian.
focusing on the brand new footage.
It starts with Asuka talking to Sabine
after she's brought her back,
like after their big reunion,
where she tells her
what's going on with Thrawn coming back
in the possibility of finding Ezra.
The big thing
here is the way they use the dialog,
like they cut
a couple of different scenes together.
So it's kind of janky just cutting a bunch
of different parts of episodes together
where she says when the stakes are this
high, it takes a master and an apprentice.
they did this in the previous trailers
to where they said, A new Jedi will rise.
And it was meant
to be a reference to being.
So a lot of people had questions
about this.
Does this mean that Sabine Wren
is now for sensitive
because they were very ambiguous about it
during Star Wars Rebels,
She wielded the Darksaber
and when Kanan was trying to teach
about it,
Kanan jurors was trying to give her lesson
so that she had problems connecting
with the force because of her past trauma.
a lot of people took that to mean
that she wasn't for sensitive
because you can wield the darksaber
without being force
sensitive like Bo-Katan.
Kryze is not force sensitive.
She used the Darksaber just fine.
what I think they were doing at the time
is that Dave Filoni just didn't
want to address Sabine being for sensitive
like it wasn't meant to be a big story
arc during that series.
It was just more focused on the darksaber
and the history of the mandalorians
around the Darksaber.
a little while ago
when he was doing interviews
for the series,
he said that he would change a couple
things about the rebels in the Clone Wars
series, like the Canon would change.
It's like a minor bit in This
might have been what he was talking about.
like, remember when we weren't really sure
whether or not Sabine Wren was force
sensitive? What?
We're saying that she's always been force
sensitive in at least now in present day,
as much trauma
she has, she doesn't have so much trauma
that she can't connect with the force
Now it is possible for people to wield
lightsabers without being force sensitive.
They're just not quite as good at it.
And you could train someone
how to fight with a light saber
who wasn't for sensitive.
But if they weren't
going to make her force
sensitive during this series,
why would they use such specific
terminology like Jedi Apprentice master?
why would they keep comparing Sabine
and Ahsoka to Ahsoka and what happened
with an Anakin being her master
lot of questions about that too.
Like an it can never actually became
a Jedi master.
So a lot of people were like,
Why are they saying that in the trailer?
Why are they marketing it in that way?
My assumption when it comes to
that is that Dave Filoni also,
like he said, he's changing the back story
just a little bit.
Is it he's retconning in some of this
and again
Ahsoka stuff
like there'll be a couple of moments
during the series
that will mostly reference stuff
from the Clone Wars,
sort of be similar to the Clone Wars
or like Star Wars Tales of the Jedi.
When you saw a couple of scenes
with them together as well in, there'll be
at least a few moments that might conflict
with some plot points in the prequels.
if you been a Star Wars
fan for a long time,
these kind of continuity issues
aren't a brand new thing
like if you watch the Clone Wars, Star
Wars, Rebels, Tales of the Jedi,
all the modern Mandalorian stuff,
they've been all kinds of weird
continuity issues
that have popped up over the years.
And usually it's a little bit
of hand-waving behind the scenes.
And Dave Filoni, Jon Favreau, even George
Lucas kind of saying, you know what,
we thought of a better idea,
so we're going to do it this new way.
this isn't meant to be like a Disney thing
or a bunch of executives are making them
change the canon.
Dave Filoni himself is like,
I wrote all these characters.
I created most of this stuff,
so I'm going to tune things
a little bit for live action.
And this is the way
it's going to be going forward.
so at least without more episodes, like,
without having seen the entire series, I'm
going to say right now
that they'll just say that
Sabine Wren has always been for sensitive.
the other thing
most of you may have noticed
in the previous trailers
is that the green lightsaber
she's using is actually Ezra Bridgers
former lightsaber, so that might wind up
working into a big story twist later
when they actually find Ezra in the flesh.
lot of theories about what's going on
with that because later in the trailer
you see more of that fight
that Ahsoka has with Marrok.
And then I'll talk about the other clip
in a second to the other thing
about the master and apprentice
defeating enemies terminology
like the dialog they use in this is meant
to be a reference to Balan Skull
and his apprentice Chinnery
on the other side of things,
one of the big things
that are carrying forward
from Grogu's storyline,
like all of Ahsoka and Grogu's scenes
in previous seasons of The Mandalorian
as well as Book of Boba Fett, is the idea
that the two of them
are basically like the future of the Jedi
I'm not sure what they're going to do
long term with Balance School's character.
Originally, they probably had bigger plans
for Rey Stephenson,
but he just passed away.
So rest in peace.
They might wind up
recasting the character,
but they haven't really done that a lot on
the Star Wars live action series so far.
the idea, though, is that he is pursuing
his own path through the force.
It just happens to be diametrically
opposed to Ahsoka.
His path
through the force in Grogu's path.
But the whole idea is
that you have all these different people.
You have dark Jedi,
you have a light sighted or light leaning
Jedi like a so getting Roku
Who all of them leave behind the classic
traditional Jedi teachings
that Luke Skywalker is now representing?
Luke Skywalker is like the only person
in this equation who's trying to reform
the Jedi Order using the traditional Jedi
teachings of the classic order
I'm sure at some point during
these upcoming seasons of all these live
action Mandalorian Ahsoka series,
maybe like the Thrawn movie,
they'll clarify
what's going on with Luke Skywalker
a little bit more
in this part of the timeline.
there's no way
they can do the Thrawn movie
without including Luke Skywalker
in some way.
Like he's not going to completely
sit out a giant Star Wars movie
then there's a much longer scene
from the first couple of episodes
with Hera in the Phantom, with Chopper
going after this freighter
that looks like it's trying to bogart
some technology from The New Republic.
Like in the shipyards, they passed them
decommissioning a star destroyer.
This gets back to
what the New Republic was doing
during the events
of the Mandalorian Season three.
Like in this part of the timeline
after Return of the Jedi
generally, Monmouth, MA issued an order
that they would decommission
all their old ships, not just the old
imperial ships like the star destroyers,
but all the old rebellion ships too,
so that they can move forward
with something that was completely new,
like a New Republic era design language
here going out to the ship,
it looks like either some pirates
or part of the shadow council.
I think more likely that are trying
to steal New Republic technology.
That's their whole thing
that they talked about
at the end of The Mandalorian Season
three,
one of the heads of the Shadow Council,
like one of the heads
of the factions of the Shadow Council
was saying, Why don't we just continue
acting like rebels stealing things
from different space planes?
It's very, very profitable.
I because this clip is right
out of an episode.
While this is happening.
You also have a soldier fighting
with the inquisitor, Morag or former
inquisitor and Bronze Age key
droids controlled by Morgan Elsbeth.
I believe at this point,
early in the series, Thrawn himself
hasn't actually come back yet.
Morgan Elsbeth has just located him
with the Jedi Star maps,
and they're trying to find a way
to actually bring him back.
my assumption right now is these are just
on the edge of the unknown regions
like he has the secret fleet
that he discovered in the unknown regions,
and he's waiting to come back and he's
just waiting for word from Morgan Elsbeth,
his minion, didn't they have a whole bunch
of footage of Ahsoka and Grogu
who Mandalorian as well as Rosario Dawson,
talking about her own personal history
with Star Wars in a lot of antique
and Skywalker footage for obvious reasons.
like, Oh yeah, we're going to see
all these characters
at some point during the series.
So you need to remember some of this canon
A lot of people also taking issue
with the fact that she would not
train Grogu where she very clearly has
absolutely no problem training.
Sabine Wren in the force.
But I think her in-universe explanation
to Mando at the time
why she couldn't train him
because of his past trauma with order 66
does make sense
because if you think about it this way
she didn't want to train
someone who went through the same thing,
the Anakin Skywalker experience.
Now, obviously
from a very different perspective,
but she was talking about Anakin's
past trauma with losing his mother.
in the case of Grogu
her former relationship with and
and Skywalker Jedi master
like she was so close to him
and he perpetrated order 66
he very literally tried to kill Grogu
in traumatize him.
She obviously just felt like
that was too much for her to deal with.
she does not have any of that baggage
with Sabine Wren that likes the being ren
experience problem.
She has some trauma in her life,
but not nearly on the scale of Grogu,
who in order 66 in
what happened with Anakin Skywalker
like I said, my episode
one video will post late Tuesday night
and then my episode to video
will post early Wednesday morning.
Then after that, episodes will be weekly,
click here for that brand new Anakin
Skywalker Ahsoka clip and click
here for my Doctor Strange 3 video.
Thank you so much for watching.
Everyone stay safe
and I'll see you guys in the next one!